whele is with us in New York art or is
it Twyla is that how it's pronounced its
Twila yes Twila
okay I'm sorry I'm messing it up so
happy Thanksgiving what do you thankful
for I am I am thankful for the gift of
every day amen
how can I help today well I can't tell
you how glad I am I just found you and
and you have helped me just in the few
days of watching like binge watching
your you on youtube try to get my
husband on board of married for 33 years
57 years old and I am very very
concerned about retirement I really
don't have anything I have twenty
thousand dollars put away for retirement
in a 403b that my employer puts in for
me our total income our combined income
and he's retired but our combined income
is about $80,000 a year does he have
money in a retirement he has what he had
was his company laid everybody off and
kind of forced a matter earlier early
and he was able to take his 401k and we
followed the advice of a financial
adviser who I down the road disagreed on
a couple things with and after watching
you I realized that I wasn't wrong but
in a case II turned that he put it into
a credential Oh gross
into a like a newa t I guess it pays out
a certain amount every month how much is
it it's a for over $400,000 okay good so
you've got a pretty good nest egg you
just like to add to it while you're
still working and with an $80,000 income
right yeah yeah I was concerned about
like if I should be push I and he keeps
telling me you should be putting money
away for retirement because now my
employer will match a certain amount I'm
just I got this cold feet of it I'm
afraid I'm like what if everything tanks
don't you lose all your money I mean to
start with we would walk up what we call
the baby steps if
you've been binging a little bit you
probably heard me talk about that and
that is not sure we're out of debt
except your home you have any dead
except your home what we did
I'm very friend myself for this and
that's like I said when I found you I
felt like I found a kindred spirit I
it's been a struggle my husband likes
credit cards and he has he has some
spending issues we both came out of
situations with no money when we were
younger and I think it affects people
very differently because it did the
opposite for me anyway I'm a saver he's
a spender that's not happened so how
much debt do you have not counting your
own we don't mean how our home we own
our home I've made a huge case are you
100% debt-free is that what you're
telling me no how much $20,000 in credit
cards okay your first goal is to get
that paid off and get yourselves on a
budget so the two of you are on the same
page it sounds like he's trying to treat
this like it's two separate entities
like you need to save for retirement so
they you well let me just tell you half
of his 401k is yours you're married okay
so now you need to start treating this
as one goal that we are gonna have
enough for retirement and we are gonna
have a spending plan that we agreed
where the money's gonna go it's not
going to include any debt or use of
credit cards and we are gonna get rid of
$20,000 in debt and then we are gonna
build an emergency fund of three to six
months of expenses then is when I would
start loading up your 401k and I mean
put all you can put into it and put it
in good growth stock mutual funds now
let's address the issue then that you
know what happens if everything tanks
okay good well stock mutual funds would
have 92 200 of stocks in them of
America's best and brightest companies
so you would read down the stock list
and you would read stuff like coca-cola
Dell Microsoft Apple Home Depot General
Motors Ford you would read names like
that okay in order for those
stocks to all be worth zero America
would have ended as a country oh okay
think about it if you take every major
company that is in your mind when you
start naming off a hundred major
companies and they all were broke the
only possible thing would been that
there was a political implosion and you
know someone took the country over right
it would not be the economy could not go
down far enough without a political
collapse for all of the top 200
companies in America to be zeroed now
can they go down in value yes they can
go down in value but to all be to zero
is is virtually impossible in a scenario
where you're worried about money
if they all go to zero you need to be
worried about bullets and water and a
generator right okay I mean because
you're living in a post-apocalyptic
world at that point
and so I not going to go to zero now can
they go down in value yeah in 2008 was
the largest drop other than the Great
Depression and they went in half yeah
and I saw that that's what kind of yeah
and so if your follow me through though
if you had four hundred thousand in
there in two thousand six or seven and
then it went in half it goes to two
hundred thousand if you didn't take it
out the Dow at that time the Dow Jones
Industrial Average was sixty five
hundred today the Dow is twenty eight
thousand yeah so you're two hundred
thousand would have grown I see
sixty-five into twenty eight what five
times roughly so you're two hundred
thousand it went from four hundred to
two hundred if you left it alone it'd be
worth a million today
oh wow okay so that's your downturn but
you have to follow it with the upturn
you can't just look at the down and so
the way you do this stuff is you read
things like that you understand things
like that and you sit with a good
financial adviser and you can get with
one of our smart investor pros that we
recommend and they'll have the heart of
a teacher and you learn things
like that because the only way you get
peace you are wise to not have peace
right now because with the knowledge
level you've got it would be illogical
for you to have peace it's logical for
you to go all I know is those trucks are
going really fast and I'm not gonna step
in the interstate somebody run over me
right but if you go okay wait a minute
now I've got some knowledge there's a
crosswalk up here that flashing light
means they are all stopping we're
waiting on them to stop and then we're
going to go across real safely now I've
got some knowledge and I don't have to
go out there and play Frogger in the
middle of interesting get run over and
so you're wise if you don't know what
you're doing to have some fear the way
the fear dissipates is is with knowledge
and so another example is this when you
bought your home they did not give you a
guarantee that it wouldn't go down we
went we made a huge amount on our own on
the home that we sold run I sold when
the market started going crazy in our
neighborhood and we bought four to two
and change but it was 28 years ago and
we sold for 980 something and the
realtor tried to get me to sell for 8
and change 800,000 and I hear something
all you had There you were not you
didn't have a PhD in real estate all you
had there was never my gut but you know
you had street smarts yeah because you
grew up around there you had a feeling
for this neighborhood you knew what was
gonna happen you had a gut and all of
that was based on knowledge and so the
fact that you could make those moves and
make those decisions or knowledge based
rather than fear based and so if you had
that level of knowledge that street
smarts about mutual funds for your 401k
investing and I do then you'd have the
exact same feeling about that as you do
about real estate and I do so I'm very
comfortable with the volatility of the
stock market because I'm not gonna cash
it out I'm just gonna ride it out no one
gets hurt on a rollercoaster unless they
jump off and so that's what you learned
you know in the history of the market
you look at this mutual fund and go god
I'm buying a mutual fund is 27 years old
and out of 27 years it's had for years
it lost money and the average annual
return on it is 12 and a half percent
that's a pretty good thing I can look at
gives me a lot of peace and that's what
you're studying and learning and you get
that information with a smart mr. fro
and they'll help you walk through this
honored to have you as a new listener
thanks for joining us and Happy
Thanksgiving